hey babe um I made a really big decision
without consulting you
I went by a puppy rescue stand on
University Avenue I had to so I've got
to tell you something okay these rescue
dogs have had some tough situations and
a lot of them take on the personality of
their owners
this dog was owned by rapper ice-t oh
man you you suck mod this house thing
okay buddy take it easy see nothin ever
been easy for me in my life
hooked me up with a treat you want to
treat buddy hmm yeah that's a tasty ass
treat right there now give me the whole
bag okay one treat is enough [ __ ]
without talking to you give me the whole
bag of treats cuz I'm a treat killer and
a mother leave my ass right up on this
comfortable ass sofa I'm gonna sleep on
this [ __ ] - I've matter of fact you
know what mother and [ __ ] I'm a pithy
appear to know raise your hand at me
okay
I've got something for you little guy ha
ha ha you wanna play fetch your play
fetch you like you both y'all
condescending mother I ain't your
entertainment [ __ ]
so you
hello who is this come on Coco don't
worry about the mother that's my [ __ ]
cocoa oh I forgot to tell y'all she's
gonna be living here too
Wow okay you got your little friend here
yeah yeah well you cannot play here for
a while sure
puppy playdate yeah lady regal ample
date that's we gonna have [ __ ] come
here [ __ ] are you doing that oh no
don't do that oh yeah that's my Shih Tzu
okay oh dear daddy here it's about to
get graphic in it [ __ ] with me keep
this area clean key & peele all-new
episodes Wednesdays at 10:30 on Comedy
Central
[Music]